yeah so from the outside it you know the
first company link exchange that I
co-founded seemed like a success it was
actually a pretty sad thing selling the
company most people actually don't know
the reason why we ended up selling the
company it's because the company culture
just went completely downhill I remember
when it was just five or ten of us it
was and like your typical calm back in
the day this was 1996 and we were
working around the clock
sleeping under our desks had no idea
what day of the week it was but it was a
lot of fun and but we didn't know any
better to pay attention to company
culture so by the time we got to a
hundred people we hired all the people
with the right skill sets and
experiences but not all of them were
culture fits and yeah when we got to 100
people I remember I myself dreaded
getting out of bed in the morning to go
to the office and that was kind of a
weird feeling because this was a company
i co-founded and if I felt that way I
wondered how all the other employees
must have felt so we ended up selling
the company and what Zappos wanted to
make sure that I didn't make the same
mistake again so from the beginning
culture has always been really important
and to this day culture is actually the
number one priority in the company and
our whole belief is that if we get the
culture right that most of the other
stuff like delivering great service or
building a long-term enduring brand will
just happen naturally on its own
so I guess my definition of you know
what culture would whether a culture
would be a right fit for me personally
would just be what I want to hang out
with these people if we weren't forced
to work together and at link exchange
the answer was no I mean that's athis
the answer's yes in fact most employees
when they leave the office leave to go
hang out with others hapless employees
and we spend our weekends together and
so that was really yeah that's probably
the criteria I use for whether a culture
it is right for me
well our whole belief is that if you get
the culture right then most of the other
stuff will happen naturally out of it
but it really depends on you know what
the culture isn't so that it's a big if
we're us we've kind of formalized the
definition of our culture into our ten
core values so if you do a Google search
for SAP those core values you'll see
what those ten are and I guess in
Herring in those 10 needs to be stuff
that is relevant to business for example
one of our core values is to embrace and
drive change I think that's really
important for business another one is
about being adventurous creative and
open-minded and another one is do more
with less and so I definitely think that
the core values need to incorporate
business concepts but they don't
necessarily need to sound business see
for example other companies might say
increased company efficiencies which is
exactly what do more with less means
we're just less formal about it
in terms of the actual wording